one main theme emerges from the charges
facing Benjamin Netanyahu both in their
content and in his response the Israeli
Prime Minister's concerned for what his
critics call his obsession with his
media coverage after a three-year flood
of systematic and partial leaks that is
about time that the public hears
everything
also my side and a complete whole manner
without mediators without censorship and
Distortion
that was his reasoning he said for
requesting that his pre-indictment
hearings in front of Israel's Attorney
General should be televised avec i
Mandal 'but rejected that his offer
suggesting Netanyahu's lawyers
concentrate on their case not public
opinion he is recommending charges
against Netanyahu in three separate
cases each with its own code number in
case 1000 Netanyahu and his wife Sarah
are alleged to have received in some
cases requested gifts from billionaire
associates totaling more than $200,000
case 2000 refers to what the Attorney
General calls an offer of a bribe by the
Israeli media magnate on on Moses
Netanyahu's accused of discussing a plan
to disrupt a competitor to Moses is
daily newspaper if Moses reporters
covered Netanyahu more favorably the
charges under consideration in both
cases fraud and breach of trust but it's
in case 4000 where the greatest peril
lies for Netanyahu he faces possible
charges of bribery a much more serious
crime
Netanyahu's alleged to have used his
then power as communications minister as
well as Prime Minister to change
regulations favoring the owner of
Israel's main telecom company the
alleged payoff
not just positive coverage on the news
site wala but what the AG calls an
extraordinary intense relationship with
the Prime Minister and his wife
dictating details of content and
presentation and the prosecution has a
valuable asset in the shape of [ __ ]
filbert a longtime close confidant of
the Netanyahu family who turned state's
witness last year it's going to be very
very difficult to attack that witness
when will Phil Burr who was so close to
Netanyahu pointing the finger at him and
again that is what distinguishes case
4000 from the other cases the other
cases there isn't necessarily a insider
Netanyahu person who's pointing the
finger
one option for self-preservation has
eluded Netanyahu last month stalemate
election preventing any new legislation
that could have granted him immunity his
main rival Benny Gantz maintains that he
won't share the Premiership in the unity
government with someone facing
indictment with those talks failing
Netanyahu's likely to return the mandate
he received from the president just last
week to try to form a government
he knows time is against him if he's
indicted but tries to stay in office
he'd be likely to face a supreme court
judgment on whether that would even be
legal as well as increasing political
pressure to step aside Harry Fawcett al
Jazeera West Jerusalem